[Music]
[Children play on the steps and in the courtyard outside a school.]
[Narrator:] Hello. Here are Mary Jane and
Tommy Davis. Let's follow them into the classroom.
[Children make their way up the school steps and into the classroom, finding their desks.]
[Narrator:] Shh. Miss Allen is going to speak. She gives out special project assignments on sleep,
good posture, and Mary Jane and Tommy are assigned mouth health.
[Children come down the steps, leaving the classroom.]
[Narrator:] They wonder what in the world they can do with a subject on mouth health.
The study of oral hygiene just doesn't seem to suggest anything for a project.
They don't realize how interesting it really can be.
[The two children walk down the street, puzzling over their assigned topic.]
[Narrator:] Of course! Their friend, Dr. Wilson, the family dentist will help them.
[Mary Jane and Tommy see the dentist's sign and dash towards Dr. Wilson's office.]
[Narrator:] Hmm. Wonder if he's busy.
[Mary Jane and Tommy peer into the office, noses pressed against the window.]
[Narrator:] Miss Young, the dental assistant, welcomes Mary Jane and Tommy.
They tell her about their project assignment.
The dentist, Dr. Wilson,
has just finished cleaning Carol's teeth,
as he has done every four months since she was two years old.
Since the dentist is busy, Miss Young takes
the children into the waiting room
to show them a book which may suggest some ideas for their project.
Each year, Carol has had an x-ray of her teeth, which would have shown a dark spot if she had had a small cavity .
The x-ray is a detective,
which indicates the positions of the permanent teeth,
which are forming here below the first,
or deciduous, teeth .
This early detection helps to prevent larger
and more expensive fillings later.
In the meantime, Miss Young has been showing the children pictures of the first, or deciduous,
teeth of a six-year-old child. The permanent teeth are forming at the ends of the roots
of the deciduous teeth, as we noticed in the x-ray.
[ Music ]
[Narrator:] Miss Young suggests that since tomorrow is a holiday, she will take them to see the orthodontist,
Dr. Martin, who has many dental models and charts.
And besides, Dr. Martin may even let them ride his son's pony.
[The children approach the gate of Dr. Martin's home, where a sign reads Happy Hollow,]
[Narrator:] Well, here they are at Dr. Martin's home office.
Looks as if his son, Scotty, is getting a pony ride.
[ Music ]
[Narrator:] Miss Young will go with Scotty so that Dr. Martin can take more time from his
laboratory work to show the children the exhibits. Let's listen in.
[Dr. Martin:] In this exhibit, Mary Jane and
Tommy,
notice how the shape of the face changes as the jaws and teeth develop.
At birth, teeth are already forming in the
jaws.
Yet the first tooth doesn't appear in the mouth until about six months of age.
[Several models and posters of teeth and jaws are displayed.]
[Dr. Martin:] Between five-and-a-half to seven-and-a-half years of age, the first permanent,
or sixth-year, molars make their appearance, back of all the first teeth.
They are the most important, since they influence the position of all the other teeth.
At 14 years of age, the shape of the face
has taken on adult proportions.
All the permanent teeth are in the mouth, with the exception of the third molars, or wisdom teeth,
which come in sometime after the 17th year.
[ Music ]
[Dr. Martin:] So let's go into the garden and discuss these models of children's teeth.
They're good examples of orthodontics, or the straightening of teeth.
[Mary Jane, Tommy, and the orthodontist sit down at a table in the garden, under a tree.]
[Dr. Martin:] Now here's a picture of a boy who sucked his thumb when he was a baby.
Notice how the upper teeth protrude and the chin recedes.
And see how his appearance has been improved by orthodontic treatment.
This is a plaster of Paris model of a boy's
teeth before and after correction.
[Tommy rests his chin on his hand.]
[Dr. Martin:] Now Tommy, you know that sleeping or resting the face on the hand
may cause irregular jaws and teeth also.
[ Music ]
[Narrator:] Now that Miss Young is back, the dentist invites his guests
to the lunch that has been set out in the back yard.
[ Music ]
[A housekeeper is laying the table for lunch. There are a table, several chairs, and an umbrella shading the table. All sit down.]
[Narrator:] This properly balanced meal consists of celery, which exercises the jaws and teeth.
A lettuce and tomato salad and milk, the most important of all foods.
Deviled eggs. Whole grain bread and butter. And fruits complete the lunch.
Since it is good practice to clean the teeth
following each meal,
Miss Young offers to demonstrate an accepted method of tooth brushing.
Let's hear what she says.
[Miss Young:] Follow a regular toothbrushing method.
And always begin at a definite place.
[Miss Young holds an oversize model of the lower teeth and demonstrates proper brushing.]
[Miss Young:] Put the  brush high up on the gums, with the bristles pointing at the roots of the teeth.
Use considerable pressure, brushing toward the chewing surfaces.
This enables the bristles to penetrate and clean between the teeth.
Continue around the mouth and repeat on the inside.
Make eight to ten sweeps in the same location, and again on the lowers.
Brush toward the chewing surfaces inside and outside.
Use a back-and-forth [motion] -- and be sure to scrub them well.
[ Music ]
[Tommy attempts to use the oversized toothbrush to brush the pony's teeth. Miss Young intervenes.]
[Narrator:] With all that they have learned,
it is now easy as well as entertaining
for Mary Jane and Tommy to make their school project.
[Mary Jane and Tommy work assiduously with paper and craft materials to complete their project.]
[Narrator:] Even a neighbor's twins are inspected. What? No teeth?
[Mary Jane works on the scrapbook, lying on her bed.]
[ Music ]
[Tommy completes the final assembly and Mary Jane sits decisively on the scrapbook to set the glue.]
[Narrator:] With their scrapbook finished, they proudly
take it to school to present it to Miss Allen.
[Children scramble up the schoolhouse steps to their classrooms.]
[Mary Jane and Tommy present the scrapbook to their teacher.]
[The scrapbook is titled The Value of a Smile.]
[One of the first pages is a hand-drawn picture of the dentist with the words, "Our friend The Dentist (see him often)."]
[Next page is a hand-drawn picture of various fruits, vegetables, eggs, and a milk bottle.]
[Narrator:] The title of the book was "The Value of a Smile." We know how much a dollar is and how
[Next page is a hand-drawn picture of a tube of toothpaste, a toothbrush, and a tooth.
[The final page in handwritten letters, "The
End."]
[Film ends abruptly.]